problem 17
michelle read a book review and
predicted that the number of girls who
who will like the book will be more than
twice the number of boys who will like
the book so she predicted that the girls
would be more than twice let me draw a
box it out more than twice
the number of boys who will like the
book which table shows data that
supports her prediction so essentially
we just need to find one of the tables
where the number of girls who like the
book that's just this column right here
the number who liked the book should be
more than twice the number of boys
so see the girls here is 40 the boys
here are 35 there are more girls than
boys but it's not more than twice the
boys the boys are 35 twice the boys
would be 70 and girls is definitely not
more than 70. so that's not our answer
let's just go here
boys well here the boys are more than
the girls which definitely isn't going
to be the case we need a situation where
the girls are more than twice the number
of boys so that's not our situation
because the girls are actually smaller
than the boys here
here we have 35 boys if you if you
multiply that by 2 you would get 70 boys
so twice the boys is 70 and we see that
the girls at 80 are more than twice the
boys at 70. so that is our choice the
girls are more than twice the boys and
if you look here the boys and girls are
even so the girls are definitely not
more than twice the boy so we know
definitely that b
is our answer
let me go to the next page
problem 18
problem 18.
anna has the letter tiles below in a bag
and it's very interesting it just
happens to spell out statistics
she reached in the bag and pulled out an
s
she then put the tile back in the bag
okay so
all of them are still in the bag if anna
randomly selects a tile from the bag
what is the probability she will select
an s again so this is a trick question
on some level because this first part of
the of the first part that she reached
in the bag
and pulled out an s and then she then
pulled the tile back in the bag
that doesn't do anything the fact that
she pulled out an s and then put it back
in the bag that shouldn't change what
happens after she took out the s and and
kept the s out then this would be a
different type of problem but since she
took the out bs and put it back in this
is almost useless information we still
have all of these letters in the bag
then it says if anna randomly selects
if anna randomly selects a tile from the
bag what is the probability you select
an s so all we have to say is all of
these are in the bag so what are the
possible outcomes so there's 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 possible outcomes
10 possible outcomes so that's going to
be the denominator for our probability
and then what are the outcomes that
satisfy our conditions or what are the
outcomes where she selects an s
she selects an s so there's 1s
two s and three s's their three out of
the ten situations involve selecting an
s so the answer is three tenths and the
reason why i said it's a trick question
is because they write this first
statement which really doesn't
change the problem at all she took an s
out she put it back if she said that she
took out an s and then she did not put
it back in the bag then you would say oh
g then there's only nine tiles left and
only two of them are s's and then you
would have said two ninths but since you
did put the s back in the bag we could
say okay there's ten ten letters in the
bag three of them are s's so the answer
is three tenths
problem nineteen
the scatter plot below shows the ages of
some children and the distance each
lives from school so this is the ages
and then this is the distance in that
axis all right
which statement best describes the
relation between age and distance from
the school
well you know just looking at this i
really don't see any relation it seems
to be fairly random but let's see what
the statements tell us
let's see what the statements tell us
right here
as age increases the distance from
school increases
not not really i mean that would look
something like this so
if age and distance if so this is our
age axis this is our distance axis
what a is describing is a increases the
distance from school increases the data
points should look something like this
they should generally increase distance
generally increases age increases that's
not what we see here i mean this really
kind of seems arbitrary it's not like
this nice upward trend
b as age increases the distance from
school decreases well i don't even see a
downward trend either that what b is
describing the data would look like this
where we have kind of this downward
trend i don't see that here either
see as age increases the distance from
school remains constant well what that
describes what c is describing
would have data that looks like this
that regardless of age the distance from
school is about the same
i don't i don't really see that either
there's still a huge spread of distances
and then d
there is no relationship between the age
and distance from school i'll go with
that one because you can imagine you
know if i tried to draw a trendline well
i could draw something like that maybe
that makes it look like there's a trend
but i just as easily could have drawn in
that and that looks just as good to me
or i just as easily could have drawn
that none of these look like it fits the
data any better so the at least the
answer that i feel comfortable with is
d